et maintenant les messieurs
ouais si championnat football
les heureux de vous connaître
elisa tovati qui joue le rôle de
chochana boutboul dans la vérité si je
mens 2 qui a fait 8 millions d'entrées
oui laisse rêveur l'énorme le rendre
connaissiez et on a tourné un
court-métrage ensemble ah oui camarades
de travail
alors est-ce que sucer c'est tromper ça
veut dire bol je vais pas voir ce que
vous avez vous non et donc c'est de vous
dont josé garcia tombe amoureux dans le
film la vérité si je mens 2 bien raison
voilà il a bien raison
le papa d'élise ya donc elle est
beaucoup cette chanson il vous a appelé
voilà est en fait tout va this par votre
salon vous appelez touati parce qu'un
jour sur le tournage de macho de bigas
luna
il ya un type qui a fait une erreur
camille un v à la place du vous ai dit
c'est mieux oui je cherchais un nom je
me suis dit bon allez je vais trouver
quelque chose d'autre et quand j'ai vu
trop hâtives mais si c'est sympa tout le
monde saura moyens humains est alors
votre réseau en fait c'est zaz ou c'est
mon petit surnom
voilà ça vous en faites pas vous appelle
bien là catherine qui me dit dans
l'oreillette que vous avez votre joie
n'en veut de boula et alors non mais
l'auto voilà je demande des comptes
c'était bon mais on est en paix nulle
part on pourrait imaginer que sera
plateau de téléviseurs normalement les
tranquilles banon
regardez le bien alors c'est très sexy
mais vous dites là j'ai toujours peur le
très sexy mais j'ai toujours peur qu'on
me voit comme une fille pulpeuse les
gens sont cons j'ai pas peur qu'on le
voit comme une fille pulpeuse parce que
quand on est plus pesant neptune peut
savoir ce que je dis souvent c'est que
c'est vrai que quand on est une jolie
fille souvent les gens s'arrêtent à ça à
ça et j'ai toujours essayé de montrer
qu'on pouvait être pulpeuse au sexy et
avoir autre chose aussi dans la tête
même si bon vous savez quand même je
suis plus peut on en arrive à la
cheville 69
vous connaissez le principe
donc la question de la fiche 69 c'est
vous qui me les rôles sont inversés
c'est vous qui me posait la question que
vous voulez et visa d'accord bon je me
dit j'ai pas de slip moyenne il ya une
citation d'oscar wilde que j'aime
beaucoup c'est un auteur que j'apprécie
énormément nom revient le range toujours
là car white ma copine
la citation dit que la chance est un
talent et je sais que vous avez beaucoup
une chance dans la vie que vous avez
beaucoup de talent mais moi ce que je
voulais savoir c'est qu'il y avait à
faire un choix entre avants du talent ou
est riche il avait choisi j'ai l'abri
pognon déjà non alors justement de
non-réponse jalousement ccc besoin d'un
compte sérieusement et plus grosses
conneries que j'ai pu faire dans ma vie
c'était toujours par appât du gain et
les trucs que j'ai fait de mieux dans ma
vie c'était des choses qui au départ
n'était pas censée rapporter beaucoup
d'argent
cela vous va comme réponse bien merci je
crois qu'on va devenir très copains tous
les deux avec bilal que le côté non mais
vous vous avez déclaré je me sens
m'ennuierait d'être considérée comme la
conne avec des gros nichons
je préfère qu'un mec tombe amoureux de
moi quand je suis en jean et un t-shirt
donc aujourd'hui une angie bon voilà
donc ce qui vont tomber amoureux du
aujourd'hui ce sera pour de vrai il ya
toujours des grands
mais la romane bohringer ya deux
semaines le fait c'est devenu un rituel
ma va bien ce que fabien bien non mais
c'est vrai quand vous dites bon je
connais un mec si même en jeans anti xa
le jour où je mets la jupe et décolleté
surprise c'est la surprise du chef
voilà c'est le bonus c'est le petit plus
vocation très tôt j'ai toujours été très
flou oui un depuis votre plus jeune âge
je suis très gourmande de la vie j'ai
toujours eu beaucoup la pêche petit
faisait des spectacles avec miss earth
regardez moi ne lui s'occupait pas du
reste du monde visage
regardez moi mais tous les deux à
wallace voilà on est tous les deux et
donc c'est vrai que j'ai eu la vocation
tout de faire rire faire pleurer amuser
les gens et ça m'a plu très jeune donc
j'ai comment je gère mes deux mains posé
la question de faire autre chose enfin
non vraiment ça a été comme une évidence
pour moi là alors que j'ai fait quelques
années de cours de théâtre de casting
comme tout le monde a un peu galéré
votre premier rôle bas c'était dans
macho de bigas luna ça a été un pour moi
formidable de tournée en espagne doit
rencontrer un metteur en scène comme
bigas luna qui est quelqu'un de très
inciterait aspire inspiré par dans celle
ci dans cette attente est aspiré n'est
pas nominé
oui beaux parents parce qu'on a beaucoup
parlé du dit papa et des plombiers vous
parler d'andré de dettes et bernard et
eli lilly c'était comment par rapport à
votre vocation voyez ils m'ont laissé
faire ce que je voulais parce que y
voyez que j'étais d'abord sérieuse à
l'école et vu que c'était une réelle
passion je lisais beaucoup les pièces de
théâtre je travaillais j'étais une
bosseuse donc ce n'est pas comme si on
dit je vais être comédienne
ensuite vous fait soleil de roger hanin
avec sophia loren et puis philippe
noiret et sophia loren vous choisi en
disant que vous lui ressemblez un petit
peu quand elle était quand elle était
jeune c'est pour ça qu'elle vous choisi
vous et là il ya un problème parce que
vous êtes obligé de ne pas participer à
la vérité si je mens numéro un c'est
toujours la victoire
ouais six mois d'enfer dunois deux films
en même temps
bah pourquoi je vais faire attention
et donc j'ai dû faire un choix et c'est
vrai que sophia loren c'est une telle
comédienne
moi je rêvais de travailler avec elle un
jour on me propose c'est difficile de
dire non
donc j'ai accepté et est donc j'ai pas
pu faire la vérité si je mens mais quand
la vérité si je mens 2 cancale casting
en plus et était restée quasi nul et
toutes les comédiens nulle part et
mannequin présentatrice de télé tout ce
qui était brand entre 20 et 30 ans
étaient convoqués j'ai un handicap c'est
que j'ai pas fait le premier
complètement vouloir j'étais persuadé
qu'il allait m'en vouloir je suis arrivé
j'avais un peu la trouille je me suis
dit bon c'est clair ils ne prendront pas
et au début je dis peut-être qu'ils se
souviendront pas que j'ai fait le
casting du 1 évidemment bonjour alors
comme ça tu n'as pas voulu faire vérité
si je mens et puis finalement
ils ont été juste vous en prie voilà
donc votre personnage de chochana
boutboul dont vous avez pas fait
l'erreur de la jouer juive tunisienne
vous avez un peu réfléchi aux
personnages garde quand même m'a laissé
la place de de proposer des choses et
j'ai voulu la faire justement très
fraîche et pas stéréotypé
voilà des plus de succès que les garçons
maintenant depuis vous avez fait ces
trois films non non c'était un peu
compliqué pour jouer un comme rien avant
17 ans oui non mais c'est fou qu'est ce
qui se passe et pourquoi j'étais très
timide et puis je sais pas les hommes
vous n'êtes pas vers moi je les
intéressais pas je faisais 700 kg et
même le premier même le premier c'était
pas terrible est devenu le premier
c'était beau parent n'a pas vraiment osé
en plus alors là vous raconter très bien
l'histoire est remarquable oui dit il à
avancer puis reculer il à avancer puis
reculer
l'idée est elle a déjà nié il exhibe
était le bon ah bon ça c'était la bonne
idée mais bon et alors vous dites un
moment j'ai pris les choses en main et
s'est laissé faire mais souvent les
oignons d'expérience qui sont face à une
jeune fille qui en a pas ils sont un peu
tétanisé donc parfois faut prendre les
choses en main c'est l'udf et alizée
vous avez quand même des problèmes au
départ pas été évident je crois que
c'est pas évident pour beaucoup de
personnes s'étaient pas les dents si
vous regardez beaucoup les dents chez un
ami le père de notre ami et chirurgiens
dentistes
quand elle voit quelqu'un regarde pas la
télé achat sera choisie vous avez
très belles dents voilà c'est votre
perte ben non alors il ya un gros
problème quand même ah bah oui c'est
votre fiancée bien montréal oui et c'est
un gros problème mais ils m'auraient ya
les accents mais là l'accent il
alexandre vi vendeurs attendent la
mi-temps bûcheron à mi temps ça tout à
fait réparé mais comment comment ça se
passe selon ça se passe très bien il
suffit simplement de prendre des avions
et puis les factures de téléphone sont
un tout petit peu plus élevé c'est tout
mais la distance n'a jamais gêné
personne pour pour être amoureux et
vivre de belles choses donc moi je ne
mets pas de barrière je peux je veux
bien aimé quelqu'un à l'eau bout du
monde pourvu qu'ils soient formidable et
qui m'apporte qui m'apporte lui le
fidèle là bas mais on n'est jamais sûr
de personnes même quand quelqu'un habite
à côté de vous donc quand ils baisent
elle va se déclarer vous aussi
mais vous êtes fidèles comme fille ah
oui moi je suis n'est pas le changement
bonjour elle qu'un nas et intègre et
fidèle et puis si je rencontre quelqu'un
d'autre je préfère dire bon dans ses pas
jouer un double jeu
je sais pas mentir ses fidèles si vous a
coûté pas mal de mecs d'ailleurs d'être
fidèle au dessus des fois vous titille
avec un mec voyez pas c'est une équipe
formidable à côté et vous osiez pas vrai
je connais tous de ce soir est embêté
alors ce qu'il faut savoir quand même
cher de nos téléspectateurs c'est que
une partie du choeur d'elisa tovati
restent à prendre
mon coeur est un peu comme une grande
salade effectivement avec plein de
feuilles
une partie a déjà été en reste d'autres
ça va mieux
j'ai toujours pensé que j'avais des
kilos d'amour à donner
viens donc dans le film c'est josé
garcia acquérir à la nouvelle orleans et
garcia qui est l'heureux élu et ça
s'appelle la vérité si je mens 2 années
de rosé